In 1978, John Carpenter's "Halloween"
was released and became an instant hit
that spawned a huge horror franchise. It’s
a beloved classic, but not everything in
the series was well-received. Here are
examples of questionable storylines.
With over 10 entries in the "Halloween" canon, it
can be challenging to remember what has happened
before any given movie, and that's not entirely
the viewer's fault. "Halloween" debuted in 1978,
and by the time "Halloween H20: 20 Years Later"
was released in 1998, there were six movies filled
with different characters. Instead of trying
to tie together the plots of all the films,
"Halloween H20" retconned everything outside of
the original movie and its sequel. In this version
of events, films four through six never occurred,
meaning Laurie Strode never had a secret daughter
who Michael Myers murdered. Instead, Laurie faked
her death, assumed a new identity, and had a son.
Nine years later, Rob Zombie tried his
hand at making a "Halloween" movie,
but he started over with a rebooted,
completely separate timeline,
creating his own version of the characters. When
the franchise returned in 2018 for a soft reboot,
it erased everything except the original
"Halloween" as if it were a direct sequel
40 years in the making. It slyly addressed
this in the 2018 film when one character
brings up plot points from 1981's "Halloween
2" and is bluntly told those were only rumors.
Though the branching arcs and
characters may intimidate new viewers,
at the end of the day the series is
still relatively straightforward.
The Strode family is haunted by the trauma
of the events of the original "Halloween,"
and a relentless serial killer
terrorizes the town of Haddonfield.
"Halloween: The Curse of Michael Myers"
starts with Michael hunting down Laurie
Strode's 15-year-old daughter, Jamie, and her
newborn baby. Knowing Michael is after her,
Jamie calls into a radio show to
ask Michael's former psychiatrist,
Dr. Sam Loomis, for help. She then
immediately hides her baby. Soon after,
Michael finds and kills Jamie, but her baby
is found by a grown-up Tommy Doyle — the boy
Laurie was babysitting in the first film.
Theorizing that Michael is intentionally
targeting members of his own family, Tommy does
his best to hide the infant from the killer.
Being the nigh-unstoppable killing machine he is,
Michael eventually catches up with the baby,
and in the fabled "Producer's Cut" of the film,
a character tries to stop Michael from killing the
infant by suggesting it might be his child. Since
Laurie is Michael’s sister, this presents
the idea that he had a son with his niece.
The implication of incest is thankfully omitted
in the theatrical cut, which without a doubt,
makes it the stronger version. Given the
uncomfortable nature of this reveal, it's
probably better to stick to the wider release's
story and pretend incest never happened.
The hectic opening of "Halloween: The Curse of
Michael Myers" should tip viewers off right away
that this will not be an average entry in the
franchise. A woman giving birth is surrounded by
doctors wheeling her gurney through an industrial
area, then into a stone-carved cavern lit with
torches. Once the newborn is delivered, it's given
to a mysterious figure before the baby's mother
has a chance to hold him. The infant is then
placed on a stone altar and has a symbol drawn
in red on its stomach. Surrounding the newborn
are three figures clad in black robes. It’s unlike
anything that has been seen in a "Halloween"
film until this point in the franchise.
These robed figures are the movie's primary
villains, and it's eventually revealed that this
cult has found a way to control Michael using an
ancient rune of darkness known as the Thorn. Their
claim seems to be confirmed in the producer's
cut when Tommy succeeds in halting Michael's
rampage by using ancient runes of light. However,
thanks to difficulties with the production, the
cult storyline never fully took shape, and it's no
wonder that future sequels let it go altogether.
Though Donald Pleasence died unexpectedly in 1995,
he remains a fixture of the "Halloween" franchise
thanks to his character, Dr. Sam Loomis, and
his importance in the Michael Myers story.
Having been assigned to Michael Myers' case, Dr. Loomis had 15 years to treat the boy.
By the time of the first film
he decided Michael was no longer a man, but evil
in a human shape who had no chance of redemption.
"I realized that what was living behind
that boy's eyes was purely and simply evil."
From the moment Michael escapes, Dr. Loomis is
hellbent on taking Michael down by any means
necessary. This includes blowing himself
up, traumatizing children, giving a bunch of
locals inferred permission to patrol the town with
rifles, and holding police officers at gunpoint.
Throughout the series, the authority figures
who interact with Loomis repeatedly dismiss the
doctor and underplay Michael's threat to their
communities. This isn't restricted to police
chiefs, sheriffs, or government officials; even
the psychiatrist's colleagues believe he should
be receiving mental health counseling instead of
dispensing it. While he is undoubtedly obsessive,
Dr. Loomis is almost always right whenever
he suspects Michael is at large. The only
time Dr. Loomis is repeatedly wrong is in
his guesses of how to kill Michael Myers.
No matter how many times he tried, Loomis never
could quite get rid of his least-favorite patient.
There are numerous shots throughout
the "Halloween" franchise of Michael
locking eyes with his victims in a menacing
fashion. These are always tense moments,
as they often signal the victim beginning to
understand the danger they're truly in. These
shots also have a sort of calm-before-the-storm
vibe to them, focusing on stillness and inaction
to better punctuate the frantic fleeing and
stabbing that is usually about to commence.
However, one odd choice throughout the
franchise is the tendency to follow
a specific sequence of shots
in these interactions. First,
the camera shows Michael staring at his
victim. What follows is a reverse shot of
the victim looking at Michael. Then, the camera
cuts back to where the character is staring,
only to show an empty, Michael-less space.
Sometimes, this gives Michael the appearance
of teleporting, as the character's gaze doesn't
tend to follow him to where he might have moved.
While this is obviously an attempt by the
filmmakers to make Michael Myers more threatening,
it actually raises more questions than it answers.
In a matter of seconds, Michael seemingly warps
across the room or safely off-screen, breaking
some of the tension that was previously in the
scene. Though it may admittedly be awkward
to watch Michael walk from point A to point B
in every instance, some creative editing may
help to make these moments more believable.
By the time "Halloween: The Curse of Michael
Myers" happens, 17 years have passed since
Michael escaped from the institution in which
he was previously imprisoned for 15 years for
murdering his older sister. Upon obtaining
his freedom, he returned to his hometown of
Haddonfield to attack high school babysitter
Laurie Strode, who was later revealed to be
his younger sister. This means Michael's
murders have haunted the town for years.
However, "The Curse of Michael Myers" is
the first time the holiday seems to have
been curtailed by the local government ahead
of time. In fact, when the film takes place,
Haddonfield residents are just beginning
to fight back against the restrictions.
It seems odd that Haddonfield would go so far
as to restrict the public celebration of a
holiday entirely, and especially odd that they
only thought to do it 30-some years after the
first Myers murder. Aside from the two Halloweens
where Michael murdered one sister then attempted
to murder his other one, there have been several
incidents that probably should have been on local
officials' radars. In "Halloween 4: The Return of
Michael Myers," one of the local problems is that
so many kids have dressed up as their town's
favorite serial killer that it's hard to find
the real one. A similar problem
presents itself in the following film,
"The Revenge of Michael Myers," where a
local kid dresses like Michael as a joke,
allowing people to mistake the real killer for
a teenager messing with his friends. Instead of
banning the whole holiday, it seems like banning
the costume may have been a better choice.
Rob Zombie's "Halloween" films
are contentious among fans of
the franchise. While some admire the
depth of backstory for Michael Myers,
others find that the characterization diminishes
his impact and is unnecessary. However, what most
fans agree on is that Rob Zombie's "Halloween 2"
is one of the most bizarre entries in the series,
feeling much more like a hyper-stylized Rob
Zombie acid horror trip than a "Halloween" film.
To some extent, Zombie's "Halloween 2" follows
similar story beats to the original "Halloween 2."
Both films confirm that Laurie Strode
and Michael Myers are siblings, but
unlike the original, Zombie's
"Halloween 2" focuses more on the
psychological aspect of the characters
and delves into surrealist territory.
The film features several hallucinations
that link the siblings' minds, including
scenes in which Laurie begins to envision
herself carrying out Michael's past murders.
Eventually, Laurie is sent to an institution
similar to the one that held her brother for 15
years. Here, we see the most outlandish imagery
in the entirety of the "Halloween" franchise:
a hallucination of a white horse that feels more
akin to a fantasy film than something that should
be in "Halloween 2." Overall, Zombie's "Halloween
2" is one of the oddest films in the franchise,
and the abstract nature of the
movie is often forgotten or
ignored when discussing some of the
latter, more disliked, films in the series.
One of the most effective ways to
make a horror film scary is through
clever sound design. Most people familiar
with jump scares know that music and sound
effects are frequently used to get
a reaction out of audience members.
Beyond jump scares and the use of a film's score,
sound effects that aren't made to scare in and of
themselves can be hugely effective in ratcheting
up the tension of any given scene. For instance,
the metallic "shing" of a knife as it's drawn
helps reinforce its sharpness in the mind of
audience members, and the loud "thwack" that
rings out when that same blade is plunged into
its target can make the impact seem much
more terrifying than the visual alone.
With so much potential to enhance the mood of
a scene, the misuse of sound effects is often
glaring and can take the viewer right out
of the movie. While the "Halloween" films
generally use sound effects well, there are a few
unforgettable instances where they feel distinctly
out of place. The best example of this is found
in "Halloween 5: The Revenge of Michael Myers."
During a comedic scene between two police
officers, a series of clown sound effects,
including honking, are played during
their banter without any explanation.
"Fortunately we're lousy cops... Sorry."
"Halloween: Resurrection" features
a group of teens wandering around
the abandoned Myers house on Halloween night
as part of an internet livestream. This
reality show functions by having all the cameras
accessible for audiences to watch at any time,
and the contestant that most viewers
choose to watch is the winner. However,
little do the participants or the show's
producers know that Michael Myers has made
his way back to his childhood home, and he’s
ready to kill anyone he gets his hands on.
When it becomes clear to audiences that
contestants are actually being murdered
and aren't playing pranks on the others for views,
the mood inside and outside the house
becomes less lighthearted. Luckily,
one contestant has a friend watching who texts her
Michael's location while checking other cameras.
This ends up saving her life a couple of
times and even earns the guy a shoutout
once reporters show up to get a statement from the
survivor, who’s still wrapped in a shock blanket.
While this works well for the characters
in the film, it seems a bit suspect that
a livestream with upwards of a dozen cameras
all broadcasting live would have no lag while
operating within a small Illinois town's 2002
internet infrastructure. Aside from having
instantaneous uploading, there also appears
to be no issue with buffering or loading on
the viewing end as up-to-the-second info on
Michael is sent via text. Even if the show
was done today, there would likely be at least
a several-second-long delay for viewers at home,
and certainly, a few more seconds
to wait for a text message to send.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite horror movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.